هذه المعركه الضاريه التي تشهدها مدينه
باخموت شرقيه اوكرانيا منذ اشهر تعد
اختبارا حاسما لطموحات موسكو العسكريه
خاصه بعد النكسات التي واجهتها مؤخرا في
ساحات القتال نكسات دفعت موسكو لتغيير
تكتيكاتها على الارض ثباتت تدفع بالقوه
البشريه بدلا من العتاد العسكري حسب صحيفه
نيويوركيمز حتى الان كانت القوه الناريه
تحديدا الصاروخيه منها العامل الحاسم في
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه باوكرانيا
اعتادت القوات الروسيه انطارا المنطقه
المستهدفه بنيران كثيفه قبل محاوله
اقتحامها لكن الوضع تغير في بخموت
في القوه الروسيه كافه الضغط على المدينه
من ثلاث جهات بضخ موجات من المقاتلين لكسر
المقاومه الاخرانيه واقتحام خطوط دفاعها
تستهدف مسقط تحديدا خطوط امداداتك كيف
وتسعى لتحقيق اول انتصار كبير لروسيا في
ساحه المعركه منذ شهور
ورغم تكبد القوات الاوكرانيه
حسب
خبره في المانجا
في قوه الروس بشكل اكبر